welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and black panther Welcome To Forever had
Sherry make wakandan history by making
the world's first ever synthetic
heart-shaped herb praise bass vibranium
Hallelujah but hold on now wait a minute
how the hell was Sherry even able to
make this synthetic heart-shaped herb by
using a murdering merman's friendship
bracelet made from the same blue plant
that turned Neymar's Mama a hue of blue
and gave her gills too like what is the
secret link between the blue telecon
plant and the purple heart-shaped herb
well my nerd babies I believe that the
link between these two plants is a lot
more simpler than you think let's get
into it but first get into some new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can pick up
a cool shirt or one of our other amazing
nerd options over there we got a super
cool stuff over there 24 7. new
rockstarsmarsh.com is the best place to
go to get yourself looking right so go
visit there today right now you don't
have a choice I'm looking at you through
the window just kidding I'm not I will
I'm not maybe all right gang so to recap
after princess shuri visits the undersea
Kingdom of talocon she returns to
wakanda with the bracelet that Neymar
gave to her a bracelet made from the
same glowing blue plant that created the
water breathing talukani people and made
them say I'm blue I cannot breathe I
must dive into the ocean to survive like
Eiffel 65 I don't know why I decided to
sing terribly that's actually a dated
reference also so um if you guys have no
idea what I'm talking about
please
um call AARP
oh I'm only 30. all right here we go a
mysterious blue plants That Grew From a
deposit of vibranium in the ocean and
this of course was news to all of us
because right up into the events of
wakanda forever most commonly assumed
that MCU planet Earth had only one by
bringing a meteor crash land onto it
thousands of years ago onto the
continent of Africa but apparently that
wasn't the only time the planet had a
vibranium visitor because thanks to Riri
Williams fancy vibranium locating device
we know that there are now potentially
multiple deposits of vibranium scattered
across the planet hidden deep
underground but he realized the question
everybody what is the difference between
this weird new blue vibranium and Rich
plant found on the coast of Yucatan and
the purple heart-shaped herb of wakanda
because like Sherry notes when she's
beginning to make her synthetic
heart-shaped herb in the movie since
both plants were born in vibranium-rich
soil they share base level similarities
so what is this base level similarity
between these two plants and what makes
them look different like you would think
that because both of these plants Grew
From vibranium meteors glowing with the
blue radiation that crashed to Earth
that they both would produce the same
blue colored plants right well I think
the answer to this is actually as simple
as asking what is the base level
similarity between the colors blue and
purple and the answer to that is blue
because the vibranium meteors that hit
the planet Earth all glowed the same
blue type of costing energy it had that
energy spread out into the surrounding
soil that they came into contact with
and if you watched my last video
explaining a key ingredient as to why
Neymar is a mutant you would already
know that I believe that this blue
cosmic energy to be something known as
dark energy in the MCU and it is the
very same type of infinity stone energy
found within the Tesseract also known as
the space Stone in that name or video I
explained how dark energy was actually a
real science thing in our real reality
in that it's this invisible undetectable
energy that exists all around us it
makes up like 68 of the entire Universe
it is the main reason why NASA nerds
believe space keeps expanding bigger and
bigger every second like our universe
keeps expanding I believe that the MCU
has translated this piece of Science and
made it fiction in the best way possible
by representing the otherwise invisible
core aspect of our universe as a blue
energy source an energy source capable
of marvelous things like I don't know
giving Captain Marvel super strength and
flights Miss Marvel or super Nifty nor
powers Monica Rambo her not get squished
by Wanda Powers powering Iron Man suits
for King the Conqueror suits giving when
moves super strength and prolonged Life
Giving Thor his lightning powers being
the base of the super soldier serum
powering Hydra weapons or even powering
the entire nation of wakanda blue dark
energy radiation is the amplifier energy
of the MCU it is what triggers Marvels
which is why this is just a small part
of a much money much larger MCU theory
that I've been talking about for months
now on here and on my Twitter that I've
called the Marvel trigger Theory which
explains how all the infinity stone
energies of the MCU are tied to real
world science and how all the energies
that we see in the MCU are tied to the
Infinity Stones if you guys have not
seen my video explaining the cracks in
no way home that's when I first
introduced that theory but that theory
has evolved very much now there's a lot
more that I did not know when I make
that video anyway and hey guys the new
year is nearly upon us and that means a
new cycle of annual conventions is two
and if you're looking for the perfect
add-on to your con outfit you've gotta
get epic hero shops convest it's a
premium black denim vest designed
especially to Showcase all of your nerdy
collectible patches and bins on the
shoulder panels of the vest are various
words translated into wakandan oribesh
Klingon Valerian cindarian and
Kryptonian so no matter what fandom you
belong to Epicure shop has got you
covered and it's perfect to throw over a
graphic tee and because it's the best
and your patches and pins will really
pop on the black denim and it has
interior Pockets to hold your foam and
pockets are great I know the ladies out
there really need some Pockets why are
we not putting pockets on ladies stuff
and if you need pins and patches epic
hero shop has those too their first
collection has a black panther pen a
Loki Gator pin and a hilarious sorcerer
Supreme pin the pins are ordered in
limited amounts and their number pins
and patches make great gifts they're
cheaper than a t-shirt it's easy to
stuff in a stocking and you don't have
to worry about guessing anyone's closing
size epic hero shop knows nerds have
been cool for a while now and they want
you to dress like it too I mean look at
me I look good in this shirt and you can
look good too by going to
epiceroshop.com to get your merch on
today but all you really need to know
for this video is that blue Tesseract
energy makes you stronger and lets you
do cool [ __ ] which is why both plants
enhance the strength of their wearers
and why Shiri was able to use the
Telecom bracelet fibers to make her new
synthetic heart-shaped herb glow with
power and give her power but now we have
to focus on the main difference between
blue and purple and that is red if both
of these plants come from blue dark
energy vibranium radiation where does
this red factor into the purple
heart-shaped herb equation well to
answer this we have to consider the main
difference between these two vibranium
meteors and that is the location the
Yucatan plant grew in the ocean whereas
the heart-shaped herb formed on land in
wakanda where generation upon generation
of wakandan people have lived and died
on and have been buried on that land
this is the red factor of the
heart-shaped Earth this is chaos energy
and energy source I believe is closely
tied to the dead in the MCU like how the
chaos magic of the dark hold allowed you
to reanimate a corpse with the souls of
the Dead damned in Multiverse of Madness
or how the chaos magic of dormammu's
dark dimension and the Bloodstone from
werewolf By Night can keep humans from
deaf or how Kamala Khan's Red Energy
Within her blue dark energy powers
connected her with her great grandma
Aisha in this weird purple huge space or
even how the purple Power Stone was able
to connect Peter Quill with his mom and
recall the souls of everyone who died by
the celestial s and the Searcher on that
planet in the collector's presentation
and because red chaos energy is the
frequency of darkness in the MCU and is
therefore absorptive by Nature as we can
see from Wanda's powers of Multiverse of
Madness when she absorbed both America
Chavez and Maria Rambo's Powers how The
Ether absorbed Jane Foster's life force
in Thor 2 and how the Bloodstone
absorbed man thing's Powers making him
weaker I believe that red chaos energy
is a key factor as to why the red blood
of Marvel human beings is able to absorb
all of this marvelous radiation without
dying I believe that when the people of
wakanda die the energies in their bodies
get converted into the infinity energy
frequency of darkness in the MCU which
is red chaos energy and that energy
seeps into the ground and enriched the
plant life in combination with that blue
dark energy of the wakanda meteor it's a
mixture of red human being blood and
dark energy like this is why I believe
shuri did not see her wakandan ancestors
while taking her synthetic heart-shaped
herb it is because the actual plant was
synthetic like the actual plant itself
and did not have the energy of the
wakandan ancestors inside of it because
that's what happens when people waste
away in the earth their energy becomes
one with the plant life but guess which
wakandan ancestor wanted to be buried in
the ocean with his ancestors that jumped
from the ships because they knew that
death was better than bondage Mr Eric
killmonger himself which is what
t'challa probably did killmonger's body
was likely buried in the ocean where his
Essence was likely absorbed by one of
the many vibranium deposits in the sea
which is why the telecon bracelet
connected shuri with killmonger but to
make a long story short the link between
the Telecom plant and the heart-shaped
herb is the blue cosmic energy of the
meteors that hit the planet because Dark
Energy amplifies your strength in the
MCU the absorptive chaos energy within
the blood of the wakandan ancestors
helped these herbs absorbed more dark
energy to give the Black Panther more
cosmic power so the blood helps the
plants absorb more dark energy which
makes the plants more Rich basically the
plants to get more and more stronger by
the generation but that is what I
believe what links these two cosmically
powered plants in the MCU what do you
guys think let us know in the comment
section below but thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at mesotainment on Twitter if you
want to see me tweet some really fun
theories especially theories on the
Marvel trigger Theory which I talk about
all the time in my Twitter but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media but
again thank you guys so much for
spending time with me I always
appreciate I love you guys and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you